our governor steve sisolak is asking
fema to step in once again to help make
sure we don't face another catastrophe
that came with the pandemic
thank you for joining us at 4 on this
friday i'm kirsten joyce and i'm
christian casa as we received
2.7 billion dollars from the american
rescue plan
just a few days ago and this all comes
as the delta variant is starting to pop
up in our area and as hospitals see an
influx of new covenant 19 cases victoria
saha joins us live from the las vegas
strip to explain
how this federal money will help
victoria
although cases aren't at an all-time
high they are on the rise again here in
clark county and throughout
smoke with today say now is the perfect
time for fema to step
in so las vegas doesn't shut down after
already returning in full force
the governor's plan to use federal help
will allow for more testing sites and
pop-up vaccine clinics
as of today only 53 percent of nevada
residents started the vaccination
process
after the convention center and cashman
center closed the only options left to
get vaccinated
were pop-up clinics and pharmacies but
dr fuhrman leguin with the health
district says
help from fema can bring an additional 6
to 10 vaccine pop-up clinics
which will also help get more people
vaccinated their goal is to vaccinate
adults ages 20 to
a reason for 40. because when we look at
the number of cases of hospitalizations
and even deaths that we suffered during
the last
90 days what we find out is that
95 percent of the cases reported in
craig county
the last three months are people who are
not vaccinated
the new delta variant is a concern and
the governor's office tells me help from
fema won't necessarily come in
in form of a check but provides staffing
to new testing and
vaccine sites now the five million
dollars put away for backs nevada days
will still take place and the winner the
first winner will be announced
next week reporting live from the strip
victoria saha 8 news now